all right but we do continue on to other
news this morning one of america's
busiest airports is back in business
after a serious security breach and a
wild police chase across
two busy runways authorities want to
know how this
car got through a fence on the perimeter
of los
angeles international airport last night
jonathan vigliotti is at
lax for us jonathan good morning the
situation could have been much much more
serious
yeah good morning to you tony and it
could have been a lot more serious
during peak hours
here at lax a plane lands or takes off
literally
every single minute since 9 11 la
airports have invested more than a
billion dollars in security measures and
yet somehow
this driver managed to find that one
weak spot here making his way
through this gate behind me
this was the scene as the driver in a
silver mazda
led police on a high-speed chase across
one of the highest trafficked areas in
the country the tarmac
at los angeles international airport
huge ripple effect here after a vehicle
actually breached the airport
facilities after breaking through a
fence near the airport's fedex cargo
facility
the driver sped past a line of parked
jumbo jets
witnesses then say the car drove across
two busy runways on the airport's south
side
did a u-turn back across them before
coming to a halt
outside a private terminal the large
chain-link gate near the fedex loading
area was found completely destroyed
police gave chase most of the time until
the hatchback stopped outside atlantic
aviation
a charterjet terminal this is a really
crazy one more than a dozen police cars
surrounded the vehicle
and the driver surrendered when the car
came to a rest
the letters inexplicably for now sos
were clearly visible on the hood
and we are told that security actually
witnessed that driver
write sos on that car here in this
parking lot
before that chase began at this point
police are not commenting on a possible
identity
or motive for why this driver did this
nobody was injured in this chase but the
question this morning remains
how did a major breach like this happen
in the first place anthony yeah turned
out very fortunately jonathan thank you
very much